nfts the blockchain
the ledger social currency like a blue
check or fortnight skins
cutting out middlemen nfts are here for
the rest of our collective lives
[Music]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
i i really don't think we could have had
two more legendary guests than you two
so i'm gonna go ahead and go ahead and
let chris do some questions i'll be back
with some of my own
please all right guys so up first
we want to talk about spax this is spax
attack
after all um we had matt on last time to
to talk about omni channel acquisition
but
matt for those of uh our viewers who
were not with us last time can you give
us a bit of a background
on oca and what they're looking for um
in a target company
okay great uh nice to see everybody
again nice to see you to chris and uh
obviously we're uh we're still doing our
work so i'm limited in what i can
discuss but i can talk about
what has been in the prospectus and what
we're all about right i am very
passionate
about modern consumer businesses it's
what i live
it's what i invest in it's what i've
helped build
particularly direct to consumer
businesses and it's also a course i
co-teach at harvard business school
about how to take a consumer business
and move them along
the omni channel journey so you know
what is what does that really mean
the expectation now especially coming
out of the pandemic
is frictionless commerce right people
don't care whether you're transacting at
the register
you're ordering on your phone you're
ordering online you want to be able to
transact
in a frictionless way no matter where
you are and receive your goods no matter
how you want them
pick them up curd side and so forth so
the pandemic compressed
you know five plus years of e-commerce
adoption
into a year and that's created a lot of
opportunity but also a lot of
expectations and so my my passion is
about
operators right i've backed operators
all my life uh gary vaynerchuk and a
great group of people
and my my thought was if you could put
together a dream team
of operators of omni channel avengers
who could help
a target move along that journey you
could do something really special so
i worked really hard put together a
group of 21 individuals between the
board of advisors
great people who understand brands and
marketing and
e-com as bobby brown and then there's al
kerry former ceo of pepsi could
help get retail distribution of course
gary vaynerchuk and christina tosi
all people that i've been connected to
throughout my life who i know
know how to support a founder and help
move them along that on me channel
journey
awesome so gary i turned to you you know
you were early with some investments
facebook twitter
um i'm sure your name was a popular one
out there for some of these spacks
looking to add to their board or special
advisors so
were you approached by other specs prior
to
omnichannel acquisition yes
what what made you join on with matt and
the team at oca and really set them
apart
you know i um as some of the people that
are watching know
know i come from an immigrant background
you know i was born in the former soviet
union
most my entire business career has
really been my father
and my brother aj as my only actual
partners
and you know matt is really like a
brother to me he's really the only other
person that i've had a significant
business
relationship with when um him and steve
ross made an investment in
in vaynermedia and our fun together and
things that nature so
for me it was the comfort of the human
interaction but more importantly
i've had a front row seat um
over the last decade into what i think
is
higgins's superpower which is
talent understanding right there's a
you know i i often talk about right now
with nfts and spax and everything
there's so much debating everyone's
spending their time trying to convince
and i
i speak a lot about the thought of like
look when there's new innovations and a
lot going on
convincing um is super super
um you know fine and
interesting for people but having
conviction and executing
i think is really the
the most interesting part and i think
there's a lot of people that talk about
being good at understanding how to put
together advisors or humans
matt has put the wins on the board of
the
people and the companies that he's
backed and so you can imagine
when i started becoming educated on what
spax were which is
oh okay these companies are going to
actually have to perform
when they go public it's not private
sector capital arbitrage
it's real life how profitable are you
actually
you know there was a confidence layer
for me to go into this one
because i knew that that's all that matt
has ever really focused on which was who
are the actual practical practitioners
right you know i i heard and thank you
very much for the nice interlude of like
you know motivational but operator i see
aaron brian in the comments saying gary
talks about motivational
but looks miserable i'm not miserable
i'm focused i'm an operator these gray
hairs come
because i have a 1 500 person company
globally and i'm operating every day
and i think you know operations and
execution is going to matter chris
i think you know this 98 i mean
i think there's going to be complete
carnage with the majority of the spat
companies that go public
you know it's a hot trend to go it's a
liquidation micro event
but there's a lot of companies that
probably shouldn't be going public
because it's premature for them
they might be great companies chris but
they're not going to be great companies
in the first 18 to 24 months
from a profitability standpoint and the
market's going to chew them up
and and listen we've seen things like
facebook go from 42 to 19 to 250
like some of those companies will go on
to be incredible bets
i just would rather bet on a human who
comes from
an operational picking talent background
than let's say a vc or financial
arbitrage picking talent background
and i think that's going to be the
differentiator and i'm not interested in
wasting my time chris
if i'm going to be advising this or that
like i'd like for the
the thing to do well not to like make
myself feel good
so this was an easy course for me to
jump on yeah and you know gary you hit
some of the some of the parts of my next
question was to kind of talk about
you know how do you separate companies
you may invest in
versus a company you know that looks
good to to take public via space so
you know gary talked about profitability
and the the stage of the companies
you know i'll i'll follow up with you
matt what what do you think are some of
the key factors like determining
whether you're just going to invest in
this company you know as like a part of
rse ventures versus taking the company
public via spec
well i've talked about it in in our
prospectus too is that
that you know you want obviously
demonstrated traction i certainly feel
better than more of a
track record more evidence that i can
analyze you know
the better the more comfortable i can
feel it's just sort of you know obvious
so
i get you know very uncomfortable when i
look at somebody basically
putting forth what is effectively a
story right so demonstrate attraction
but big picture i'm i'm analyzing the
the management team and the founder
do they have what it takes to go the
distance do they have what it takes to
scale
it's very hard i miss gary knows right
to get a business from
1 million to 100 million to a billion
those transitions are all really
difficult inflection points
and a lot of it begins with the manager
that in the team of operators
what i have come to find in my
experiences no one has the full skill
set to go the distance
that's the reality and sort of cueing
onto what gary was talking about
sometimes with all due respect i feel
like if you're an investor and you're
staring in an excel sheet all
you overlook the human component nobody
has the full compliment
to go the distance and what i did with
this spac team is reverse engineered
the most common competency gaps that i
see
in a company or a founding team and to
make that a little less you know
abstract
if you have a company that's pretty much
been a rocket ship with customer
acquisition they're doing great you know
with performance marketing and whatnot
but maybe they're not so great at brand
because it's hard to find both things in
the same person
that would be one example or they're
doing really a great job
with their social mission they're
motivated you know they're they're
they're certainly speaking to the
millennial customer that wants to ensure
that their company stands for something
but they haven't been able to tell that
story
so these typical competency gaps that i
see so no matter what i'm looking at i
want to see
demonstrated chat attraction i want to
see a ceo or founder team
that has a high degree of self-awareness
greatest arbitrage
in life and in business is
self-awareness because if you don't have
self-awareness
you're going to be help resistant and i
can't make an impact so a lot of what
i'm doing is issue spotting
determining whether or not the founder
or the management team has what it takes
and determining about how can i bring
those resources to bear to make this a
better company
all right i'm going to go ahead and jump
in here and ask a question about other
specs here
um so i'll go ahead and i'll open the
question up to matt
and gary you guys can both answer is
there any kind of d
spat companies that are your favorite
out there or some that you like
oh that's interesting i uh well gary do
you want to jump in
mine's very quick matt you know i um
i don't do a lot of homework on
publicly traded companies or spax so
for me what i'm spending all my time on
is consumer behavior
which lends itself to early stage
investing so
you know i like to yap a lot and people
know that but i don't like to talk when
i don't know
and this is something i have absolutely
no nothing to bring to the table on i
literally don't even know of another
spec that exists
i know chamath has facts i know that jim
kiltz told me about spaxx four and a
half years ago and he
was kind of a father of it i know that
the draftkings thing i think was a spec
literally that's where my spac knowledge
stops and starts
outside of the fact that every day i get
asked to be to take my company
through a spec or to be a part of some
so i'm just
i'm not strong enough to answer that
question i can jump in but i'd rather
approach it
because i think it's a lot easier to
analyze a dspac let's make this more
interesting let's
analyze a pre diese pack and take a look
at what you know the
the the dislocation in the market of the
last few weeks has been sort of
fascinating to watch right you have
smacks trading below trust right make
doesn't really make economic sense
notwithstanding the treasury and we can
leave that we can leave macroeconomic
theory aside but
fundamentally doesn't make a ton of
sense so it's been interesting for me to
watch
what i believe are some really great
management teams and just a great thesis
be undervalued so a couple that i'll
throw out there that i find interesting
is one to accelerate
uh which is led by uh nardelli right and
and
just big picture what am i thinking
about when i'm looking at a spec
does this management team ceo board
have access to deal flow do they have
the ability to harness the resources to
uh evaluate that deal flow and diligence
in right
it's one thing to be able to pick up the
phone and get great inbound or outbound
it's another thing to figure out
how do you separate real cac from fake
cak you know real a to ltv from imagined
uh flywheels uh so i'm looking at do
they have the ability to marshal those
resources and a lot of that comes from
do they have great operational
background right and then can they get a
deal done
at the end you know it's hard easy to
raise money very hard to deploy
intelligently so i look at a few specs
out there that are that are really
interesting one is a
accelerate another is uh it's um it's
michael dell's
i think it's uh msd and what i find
interesting about that one
is they're partnering with greg lemkow
greg lemkow used to run investment
banking at goldman sachs
i worked with him very closely for two
really tough years of my life trying to
buy formula one
running all over the world trying to
pull up a deal but that
that guy's got tremendous access to deal
flow but he's also incredibly thoughtful
and so i get excited to see what they're
you know what they're going to do
so that's kind of generally how i've
been approaching and looking at what
kind of management team sort of meets
those criteria is another one
and it's no longer trading below trust
but is that kkr holdings
i mean they're kkr right gonna have
access to incredible deal flow
ability to marshal resources to
diligence that dfo ability to close it
and that was sort of that so that's
giving you a sense of how i approach it
i have a list of about eight that i find
interesting but i'll sort of stop there
but
that's my sequence of analysis hey
you could see the research there guys
like like gary said you gotta do your
deep research
and you guys can see matt doing his
research there so
one thing i'd like to mention and you
know we've seen this already
of sports franchises be mentioned in
specs
we know gary you've been working hard to
get towards
the jets um so my question now is you
know we know matt has some experience
with the dolphins
when do we get you to team up and get
one of these sports franchises
i mean the one thing matt knows because
we know each other so well as
there will be no conversation for me to
do anything outside of the new york jets
and i'm doing that
in a very tortoise like you know again
uh i uh i'm incredibly
incredibly patient you know the comments
in here because i don't care about
lighting
and i don't care about shaving or
cutting my hair and because i'm eastern
european and have the raccoon eyes
you know i get my eight hours of sleep
i'm a tortoise
i'm a high energy guy when i'm awake but
i'm a tortoise
out here and so i'm i'm hoping to strike
on the jets somewhere in about 20 to 23
years
i'm 45. 67 68 is a young man
gives me plenty of times to win a
lombardi so i will not be teaming up
with matt nor anyone else to buy
anything other than the jets
which would be very full circle for matt
and i because obviously he was the
president of the jets when we first met
um and so i uh that is
my i'm very narrow in my sports team
ambitions
and to be very very clear i try to use
the the jets as a weapon with
gary as a as a way to get him to sell
assets prematurely
to pay for things that i want to buy
how are you going to ride the jets i
know you're out there at the draft and
holding up the jersey
we gotta get going let's sell this and
you know it never works he is
oddly wait you would think the frenetic
one on the screen
is gary vaynerchuk but it is it's really
bore the suit right here
because carrie is very darius long money
very patient
i i'm very patient you know and it helps
me in times like you know obviously
three years ago the sports card thing
that you know i saw your promotion
pieces so you you know i assume you're
going to want to touch the subjects all
segway
you know they exploded i mean like you
know my return on that
is absurdity and it currently
probably because of that nba top shot
and a lot of energy going there
and just a million other things people
worried about inflation
there's you know we're definitely not
the top that we were
in february and like a lot of my friends
contemporaries
people that have gone in big too selling
selling selling and for me i'm like you
know
sports cards have had four of these
cycles just in the last
30 40 years like to me it's very very
easy for me to say well i still think we
got a lot more
to go here but if not this
next turn in 13 14 years
is going to be staggering like fine art
i think
the everyone's debating or right now
between nfts and art and collectibles i
think it's going to be a huge game of
and i think they're going to feed each
other i think the alternative investment
ecosystem over the next half century is
going to be staggering
and i think people's portfolios will
expand dramatically outside of
publicly traded stock and real estate
portfolios
and so i'm in the midst of this right
now where i could
exit in a substantial way and i'm
doubling down
on that asset for 13 years from now
13 years from now and so yeah i like
playing long
yeah definitely definitely that's
exactly where we're gonna go ahead and
segue so might as well go ahead and play
the nft video
[Music]
the forever phoenix you know i
definitely saw that one
and and that's all i could say there i'm
i'm i've been i am telling you right now
i'm not going to start my drawings
because
you'll probably see the same comments
that you got on some of yours gary
i know how it is art is in the eye of
the beholders
so one of the things i wanted to mention
is you know you were very early in this
industry and like you talk about it you
like the grind behind
the euphoria stage but now we're in that
euphoria stage
where do you see the ceiling here in
nfts
i believe and by the way the comment
section on this show is remarkable like
like the quality of the combo and just
big shout out to you and your community
like
i love that we're doing this on on a
back end where i can see the comments so
hey
everybody's you know the jokes of me
looking disheveled but also the very
thoughtful
you know responses and debating um
so it's exciting to say this to this
audience this is
one i think i'm gonna really nail and
like kind of show this video
in 12 years and be you know like i like
to do the recalls
this is so obviously internet to me
internet 99 2000 nfts
the blockchain the ledger the
the transactional nature of it
providence social currency like a blue
check or fortnight skins
cutting out middlemen that don't bring
value so we can track
transact like nfts are here for the
rest of our collective lives comma and
it's a big comma
the amount of money that's going to be
lost in the next 24 months
on individual nft projects because
people bought it 85
and i'm going to turn to the dollars not
eath 137
4 000 14 000 and the supply and demand
issue that is about to happen over the
next 24 months because
men and men and ladies who are watching
let there be no confusion
every celebrity every ip every league
every movie every ip every intellectual
property and every influencer and human
will have an nft project in the next 25
months
which will lead to an extraordinary
level of too much supply
and the demand will not be able to keep
up with it and so the early projects
right now that are getting
disproportionate economics
are going to be affected poorly and we
will have this april march
april 2000 internet stock moment
in the flip side when all those things
collapse there'll still be amazon and
ebay
in there the way there was in 2000 and
the macro of nfts
because it goes far beyond art in
collecting this technology
um memberships you know the royalty
aspects the
the way music and books are gonna and
movies are gonna be funded
and and distributed this is an
extraordinary moment for all of us and
i'm excited to be early on it again like
i was with
e-commerce and social media i
you're right i only know how to get
dirty unfortunately i've showered too
well no marker stains left but
um i am working on my own project
that i'm hoping to launch in early may
um matt and i are
in the final stages putting together a
vehicle from an investing ecosystem like
i'm going all in while all my other
stuff i think nft is
going to be here to stay but we'll have
a moment somewhere here in the next 12
to 18 months
where may people make a lot of jokes
about it like see that was a fad
c you know similar to icos right
cryptocurrency
didn't disappear when the ico world
collapsed
it was there was people were in that
moment of short-term money the reverse
of everything i'm excited about
short-term money let me make a quick bag
i'm going to buy a plane and a boat and
an island
by only doing something for fast for 11
months
and we're going to see that in nft land
but the macro
is extraordinary and game changing and
will have
disproportionate impact on businesses
that
sit in the middle and transact by being
a tollbooth
they're going to become remarkably
vulnerable and i think people
need to pay attention to that because
there's a back to the audience here
there's a lot of publicly traded
businesses that make their economics by
being in between the
artist or the ip and the consumer that
are going to find themselves in a pickle
in a decade because of how much ease
there is for the creator
to monetize directly with audience
without needing all that middleware
you know gary i i know you we're looking
at some of the comments we have someone
asking if you have a crystal ball
um how do you see these things so far in
the future and i gotta say you know as
as you answer these questions you're
knocking off more and more questions
that i have you know for you talking
about you know the ebay the amazon
behind this stuff
um being the survivors long term i i've
got more questions for you on nfts but i
want to turn to matt for a minute
um you know talking spax we had we had a
spac deal announced yesterday
um for tops a well-known company sports
cards
and you know doing the spac deal and
pretty much saying you know hey
we're we're going all in on nfts too can
you give us a little color on you know
what your thoughts were
on you know reading or hearing about
that top steel
i think it's interesting i mean i i gary
and i have been debating a ton
he just mentioned that we're working on
our own vehicle around nfts
i actually just to pick up on what gary
said because i don't know a ton about
tops i look at the deal i'm sort of you
know i'm wondering because
i like gary i'm seeing the frothiness i
mean all you got to do is add those
three letters to anything and suddenly
everyone is euphoric and that's not
that's a little bit of a danger
a dangerous place to be but to go back
for a second
it's the journey that gary's talking
about is the more interesting thing if
you want to bring the crystal ball out
that the glut of ip that is now running
up all these prices right
we know what's going to happen once
there's so much supply there isn't
enough demand right and those prices
begin
you know to collapse big picture around
uh and then people will lose faith
and so we have been together on this
journey around bitcoin
you know i'm going all the way back to
2013 i was mining bitcoin
gary and i invested in coinbase gary
tell me if i'm wrong i feel like it was
2013 or 14 right it was a period
no you're right pretty pretty it was 14
because i always get when i bought
aetherium and that wrong you're right we
we invest in our last fund
in coinbase in 2014. uh matt and i are
crapping our pants out of excitement we
went up heavy on
on coinbase in 2014 in our last fund
as you can imagine especially after
yesterday
chris you you're more educated on this
than i am has there been a company
that has had better economics
at the height of the heat of the
excitement of a macro trend because when
i think of google or facebook
these were companies that were on their
way when they went
ipo but they didn't seem profitable and
i'm sure the cynics or the practical or
the black and white
or the peanut counters were like yeah
but wait a minute when i see coinbase
and again even though i'm in it it's not
the biggest thing in the scheme of
things and
i'm just so undereducated on wall street
culture but
i'm i'm not a dope and i keep it
dangerous
meaning i keep my hand to it a little
bit it seems like
for something you know there aren't that
many times where there's a macro trend
like crypto and nfts and the company
that's the disproportionate leader is
coming to the
market with real goddamn numbers
i'm asking i'm very no you're you're not
you're not wrong at all and that that
was gonna be one of my questions let's
jump to coinbase so yeah those
impressive numbers yesterday and it
looks like yeah i mean
it just keeps getting better and what a
perfect time to go public
so you know the the revenue growing the
the profitability the the sign ups
you know this this past quarter was just
insane for them
so i i think it's the perfect time to go
public and i think you're spot on you
know talking about
facebook and google maybe going before
they had reached that that plateau
um so yeah let's go ahead but i want to
make a quick
wait just to finish the whole thought is
that there was a moment though in
between that journey where even i lost
enough faith but interest in bitcoin i
remember gary made a joke like
why don't we put the entire fund into
into into bitcoin i was like don't say
stuff like that you're gonna hurt
this is this is coming from somebody who
went really deep on that white paper and
understood 21 million and
was renting you know server space like i
was like don't no bad luck right
so that's going to happen with nfts mark
my words gary too
you're going to see there's going to be
this oh this was just you know a fad and
then the opportunities will really begin
to emerge sorry i just want to get that
out there
no perfect so so matt you know gary
talked about you know not being as
knowledgeable with spax and you know
kind of putting
his trust in you when it comes to that
market is is that the same here with you
know
uh bitcoin coinbase nfts where you're
putting your trust in kind of going
along for the ride with gary on the
growth of these markets
that's actually a really great question
i won't say the instance but there was
one instance when i
really lobbied gary to violate his
conviction that was more
like intuition because he wouldn't give
me data and it irritated me
and we made a very bad decision to sell
something prematurely
so so as gary knows i read everything i
love data and but
the reality is the best decisions are
gut sandwiches they begin with gotten
intuition
they're supported by data in the middle
but they end with gotten intuition right
so gary i have come to trust and
understand that like you know big
picture especially when it comes
to macro trends he's generally right and
so i have to suspend some judgment when
i'm like
really you want me to buy some kitten
you're telling me
crypto punk is gonna be worth a million
like you know he's like buy this i'm
like but
i don't know i don't think it's
interesting it's so so you know
yes the answer to your question is a lot
of it i am drafting behind my brother
over here
chris the the thing is in my older age
with these gray hairs as they emerged by
the way i love your
hair situation chris thank you thank you
america
it's all natural this is all natural so
i i
much like the transparent excuse me the
transparency i brought to this
conversation like hey i'm i'm not going
to be able to answer
this spak thing as well hey i don't
really understand how wall street wants
to decide things
when it comes to a very narrow place
which is consumer behavior
around communication layered into
technology dynamics and when i say
communication why do i know nfts are
gonna work
because i know that people buy mercedes
benzes to flex
because i know people want a blue check
on their instagram account because i
know people want followers on tick tock
because i know that people wear fashion
brands with huge logos
because i know that people wear their
facial hair or their jeans
we as human beings desperately need
to have communication to others through
our words and our actions
and so to matt's point earlier i stay in
a very very narrow place of conviction
which is
how people communicate to each other
whether that's through marketing
pictures videos written words and the
modern platforms or through the depths
of psychology of what we need for
outside affirmation
to go and navigate our insecurities or
our ambitions
and i i stay very focused on that and to
matt's point that is not an excel sheet
land
you know you'll enjoy this uh matt will
matt will start laughing
because he knows this is my standard
answer people ask me to take
you know vayner x uh public through a
spec
obviously if that even was a
consideration that would be the only one
but they always reach out and i always
say to them you do not want me to be a
publicly traded ceo
because in that first earning call when
somebody asks me
a 90 day question a short term like
why'd you lose pepsi or why did you gain
pepsi or why
something that makes no sense in a
30-year window
i'm gonna be disrespectful to the fact
that they can only make decisions
based on excel sheets and what they
learned in business school because
that's not real life
you know definitely you know one thing i
definitely have taken from you gary is
the attention that you pay attention to
and what people are paying attention to
and that and there's really i really
don't think there's anybody that
grasps that data and really transitions
it learns to monetize
it and and i'm i'm definitely impressed
by that
but let's go ahead and let's move into
sports betting here guys so i'm going to
go ahead
and play a great video here
i had to play that one that video is
really good matt you got into real good
[ __ ] i know that's a shark though
matt you looked really you really got
your [ __ ] together for shark tank
brother you look
good yeah so i saw gary for the first
time in the middle of the pandemic we
were in pictures you know what's
interesting about you matt
i never know what version of matter i'm
going to meet there when i haven't seen
you
because you know the weights go up and
down yes that is painful
that's a zing out of deep love because i
want this man on earth for 50 years and
i want
healthy behavior for my dear friend here
i i hope you guys are loving this in the
chat guys this is a real
real live conversation between you know
these two great people who know each
other they invest together so
let's turn to sports uh i want to hit on
sports betting and sports cards a little
bit more
um so so sports betting the big news
right now is you know new york
um so so matt any thoughts on on sports
betting
you've been in football for a while you
know what we see
you know increased legalization state by
state
um and what's the market look like and
how receptive you know is the nfl to the
increase in sports betting it's so
interesting how social more is you know
evolve i've been involved with the nfl
since i
you know started at the jets which was a
2004
right so the jetson and to the dolphins
i remember
early days of the of the jets i was
overseeing the business right and uh
i really wanted to be able to do branded
lotto tickets
right and so but that was considered
like a societal ill and so i wasn't able
to do a brand and i
did a whole powerpoint for the league
about how it you know actually if you
ask people
and did a study they would say that you
know hamburgers are just as bad as lotto
like that that there's no reason why we
can't do this you know when it was
eventually permitted i did a deal in
florida
my only point here we are you know a
decade later and now sports gambling has
obviously
hit the tipping point so i think it's
really interesting i am an investor in a
company called action network
i don't know if you heard about it but
creates great content and data uh
around sports gambling darren revell by
the way if you don't follow darren ravel
out there i think he's one of the
smartest people out there on
consumer trends but sports betting in
particular he's an action network so
he's where
i get my perspective but if you look at
it from a total addressable market
about 30 billion dollars at maturity
which will probably be reached by 2025
2026 so i think it's obviously
here to stay um one thing that i'm
working on is i'm one of the first
investors in the drone racing league
so we have now become licensed in new
jersey we're working on getting licensed
you know in
different states around the country so
probably my biggest lament is that i had
fanduel sitting in my office like
got to be six years ago and i was like
oh i think this is going to work but
it's kind of in the gray area and i had
to pass i like to admit all my bad
passes by the way
all within this uh 30 minute segment so
you know obviously
huge market some interesting etfs out
there i think one b-e-t-z i'm not an
investor but
interesting uh but anyway i think we're
still
maybe a quarter of the way through the
evolution of the space
awesome yeah you know way to admit on
the fan duel i just wrote about fanduel
this morning looks like
ipo you know is coming soon for them uh
you know um and yeah the bets etf we had
the round hill gang on our show a couple
times um you know great pure play basket
there
uh gary i want to turn back to sports
cards so you know
uh there there's not a lot of publicly
traded options for
investors to you know take advantage of
this market we saw collectors universe
the parent company
of psa you know bought out um
what are some ways that you know retail
investors can
you know get involved in the growth of
trading cards either you know buying
cards themselves or finding a platform
to invest in here
that's a really good question um so
for this audience i actually think this
is a practitioner moment
here's what i mean by that i think to
your
point you've got psa the the holding co
and i know
that like transacted a couple times that
sold it bought it badly um
so i know a little bit about that
there's obviously now the top
situation i think panini is a private
company there's just not a lot of
options
so for me if you're interested in that
space i actually think sports betting
and sports cards go very hand in hand
because you're really betting on either
current athletes whether it's a luca
donage or
or ronaldo cuny i think
one of the things that has made me a
good investor was sports cards you get
to understand market dynamics
so for me i think this is actually an
opportunity to get very granular hands
dirty
and actually do a little trading on
stockx ebay whatever your platform of
choices
ebay is really the dominant place and
play a little bit it's obviously a lot
more tedious you're holding real life
stuff
you get the product shipped you got to
put in a safe you can send it to pwcc in
other places
but i think this is an early stage
marketplace if you google there's
unbelief rally
and and dibs and star stock there's just
unbelievable amounts of innovation so it
might be a very high risk high reward if
you want to do the shovels and picks
in some of the innovation and there's a
ton of it obviously there's
you know the collector's universe and
tops aspect if you want to do your
public thing
though i can't speak to that because
again that's the place that's most great
for me which is what wall street does
and then i actually think my actual
answer which is especially if you like
sports
you know one of the reasons people like
betting is to make a mundane game more
exciting for them it's you're almost
paying like
an experience ticket and i think that um
one of the ways to go about this is
actually you know if you believe in sam
darnold for example
who just got traded to the panthers his
cards are extremely down
and you just might enjoy the panther
games on sunday
much more so you know worth at least a
little bit of a
of a if you want to get your
practitioner skills up to understand how
culture
and supply and demand work in the
trenches
yeah definitely you know one thing that
we've always seen from you gary is that
you've been
ahead of several trends i know i was
watching three or four years ago you
mentioned
tick tock tick tock tick tock and man i
should have been listening
i'm not even gonna lie but what's the
next what's what's coming next what are
the next trends
and what can we look out for you know
i uh i don't predict and matt knows this
about me i don't predict
where my one crazy skill is it
immediately becomes obvious to me that
it's about to happen with a lot of
humans
and then i'm all in fast i would say you
know
the other thing i was loud about that
has emerged was audio
you know i talked a lot about audio and
we've seen clubhouse pop and i think
you'll see every social platform have a
clubhouse-like feature the way snapchat
popped and then everybody had a story
feature
um i i really like
what i'm seeing with discord meets nft
projects
so i'm just gonna kind of like talk this
through this isn't a prediction this is
a
how do i help this audience maybe build
on top of this
micro thought and maybe lead to a big
breakthrough for themselves
i believe that nfts are going to create
such a transparent
community that you'll see the people
that all
owned this young music artists
early token become a virtual fan club
some of the stuff you're seeing with
facebook groups the things that
naturally happen with humans which we
congregate around common interests fan
bases
politic divides so i'm very hot on the
communication layer
on nfts let me get nerdy but
very simple imagine a world where you
have your pub you have your wallet
you're able to connect to a ecosystem of
communication
a chat a virtual room uh a message board
a facebook group like environment and
be in a place where you
are able to only be part of that
community
if you actually own the token the people
that build those pipes
around that i think are going to have a
very very large business so
what i would say is early early alpha
alpha
alpha just just just the beginnings of a
smoke of a thought
is the communication layer against the
tribes built on what's sitting
in your private and public wallets
awesome so i want to get to some
questions from the chat if you guys have
a couple minutes i know we're going over
here
um matt and i don't know if you can
answer this we had a question
from bruce in the chat talking about
morgan stanley out with the study
saying that um spax need to have pipes
lined up to get deals done
uh have you you know explored a pipe
before this uh
deal gets done or is that something you
will do once we get an announcement for
oca that's an easy question because i
could just simply
say probably not something i could get
into so no that's that's a perfect
answer
so we we appreciate the transparency and
the language
so chris anybody else find it funny that
i i like i like the the the terminology
that the spac world has created has made
me really laugh
pipes really yeah
yeah it's one of those terms out there
that you know
it and someone who writes about specs i
i i
ever thought i would so hey chris can i
jump in on something gary said for half
a second
for your audience out there if you're
looking at gary and it like seems like
he's got a crystal ball because
he was always so there before you read
about it i was making this point to the
dolphins players yesterday we do a
business combine where
we help the guys figure out what's their
career going to be after
football is pretty amazing like probably
40 guys for an hour where i'm just
talking business and i was giving them
my number one piece of advice
is that successful people are able to
act on
opportunity before the tipping point of
evidence
right not before there is evidence
before there's a tipping point and so
i have never had an original thought i
have acted early and with conviction
just as gary has so nfts look to you
like or not you the world like they just
started about three months ago
they've been around for a long time
right bitcoin bitcoin was around for a
long time before
elon musk started tweeting about it and
acquired a billion and a half worth of
it like
so my only advice to those it's not that
you
can't get access to the information
because the information is about on the
internet
as gary vee likes to say google is your
mother like go ask mom go ask google
it's whether or not you have enough
conviction and belief in yourself
to go ahead and act on that opportunity
before the tipping point of evidence i
just
want to give that overall advice because
it's not like gary and i were you know
endowed with special supernatural
powers is that we did cultivate the
ability to act with conviction early
just not good hair no definitely not
good hair
and not the ability to spell but my mom
my mom
trained me star wars style in the most
important skill set in life which is
emotional intelligence
you know i think what we are about to
see over the next century
is the incredible growth of the gray
people starting to really
delve into the depths of intuition which
today over the last 50 years
has been laughed at because it wasn't
granular we've lived through the great
era
of the black and white the school system
the get a job
the college with the internet the
blockchain and everything else
is doing is it's flipping the world
upside down
and it's creating a world that's going
to rely on emotional intelligence
kindness empathy compassion foresight
chance
lack of fear millions of other things
that happen and so
it was funny that matt used that term
because i actually cannot believe
how fortunate i am in the timing and the
luck of when i was born because the
things that i do naturally have
and the circumstances of how i was
brought up are more valuable today than
they would have been in 1967
or 72 from a business transaction
standpoint and i think for everybody
who's in the chat right now or watches
is out there
leaning into strengths and not over
dwelling on weaknesses
i think is the incredible aha at least
that i know about myself and what i
observe in matt
and every other person that i've come
across that
is in my opinion outperforming and i
think a lot of
people spend way too much time on
prevent defense using a football term
everybody sucks at most things stop
dwelling about what you suck at
focus on a strength and then go and
attack and right now a lot of people are
going to invest
in things that they don't understand
cannabis betting
um crypto nfts sports cards or
a hot stock instead of betting on things
they deeply do understand it
and when they do that they always
outperform
yeah definitely i want to jump in here
you know as you guys see my name here
story investors
i definitely think the story of is
everything a lot in this market
if you don't know the story of things
then you're not going to understand the
trends
you're not going to be able to get with
the flow before the catalyst really come
and and one of the things that i'd
mentioned that you guys are mentioning
just for traders out there
one of the best things you can do is
learn to be decisive
and that's one thing that matt just kind
of mentioned that i think
really really could stick to you traders
out there i think that's right you know
why
it's more fun to die on your own sword
when you go with conviction and go all
in for real
if you lose there's a level of
satisfaction of like well it wasn't
somebody else who did this or god damn
it i listened to or i listen this one
podcast
or gary got me into cards at the wrong
time like no no when you die
look all of us in this game are gonna
die many times
life's a video game you die a lot in
business
right business is that it's just a lot
more fun to die on your own decision
and so that conviction and understanding
makes it more
palpable the taste of losing is bad
enough
losing on someone else's opinion or push
is a disgusting feeling
i've been there you know all the chat
rooms you see nowadays
all right guys i think that's gonna wrap
up our questions we we kept you over the
time that we said i know we have a
million more questions the chat has a
million more questions
we'd love to have you back on sometime
i'm hoping we can get you guys back on
when that oca deal gets announced
so so again guys joining us on the show
today we have matt higgins omni channel
acquisition rse ventures
and we have garyvee vayners x vayner
sports vaynermedia
five times new york times best-selling
author a super new york jets fan
uh you know what a great conversation we
had you know i
i love it thank you so much both of you
for taking time out of your busy
schedules
again guys the ticker is oca omni
channel
acquisition and if you didn't hear me at
the start of the show for full
disclosure
i am long shares oca uh
thanks again guys thank you so much for
having us
awesome full disclosure i am long the
three uh stacks that i mentioned as well
i love being on and we will definitely
come back awesome thank you
cheers bye-bye thanks matt thank you
guys bye mitch
youtube bachelor what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon